nous débutons cette page actu par les
titres forcément de ce 12 septembre la
célébration du 50e anniversaire du
traité de l'elysée entre la france et
l'allemagne en pleine crise et en plein
rapprochement franco-allemand la ville
de versailles organisé un colloque
international à des rencontres ponctuées
par la présence d'alain juppé ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères la
rentrée parlementaire officiel c'était
ce mardi première rencontre avec les
ministres du gouvernement et le baptême
du feu pour les députés nouvellement
élus dont françois de mazières que vous
voyez sur ces images la députée de la
circonscription de guyancourt montigny
et n'oubliez pas ce soir édition
spéciale patrimoine au cours de la
prochaine heure des images de la
rénovation de la commanderie des
templiers à elancourt elles datent du
xiiie siècle un chantier d'un million
d'euros à découvrir pendant la journée
du patrimoine versailles de son côté
elle va proposer pour les journées du
patrimoine une visite industrielle cet
original à la découverte des chaufferies
de la ville de versailles nous et
rendront ce soir en avant-première sur
téléfilm les parlementaires font donc
leur rentrée en ce moment la nouvelle
session de l'assemblée a débuté hier
mardi
après jean philippe mallet est député
suppléant de benoît hamon dans la 11e
circonscription député ps nous avons
suivi aujourd'hui françois de mazières
lui aussi siège pour la première fois le
député apparenté ump de la première
circonscription on prend ses marques
dans l'opposition anthony rech
elodie mois
à l'assemblée nationale la salle des
quatre colonnes est en effervescence
une semaine après l'école les députés
font leur rentrée plus tôt que prévu une
reprise plutôt tendue dans laquelle un
nouveau député comme françois de
mazières député maire de versailles
pourrait se sentir perdus au milieu des
rouages parlementaire on a très vite ses
repères vous savez d'abord il se trouve
que je suis par mon propre parcours
puisque j'ai été
sous préfet j'ai été membre de cabinet
ministériel il se trouve que je connais
le fonctionnement du parlement
donc quand vous arrivez tout ça dort
très bien accueilli et vous avez très
rapidement les repères nécessaires
fait rare pour un nouveau député
françois de mazières pose une question
au gouvernement sur le dossier brûlant
de la loi sru
dès sa première séance officielle une
multiplication par 5 des sanctions
entraîneraient 4 dérive
la première c'est le poids
disproportionné des sanctions élu aux
dernières élections législatives le
député-maire yvelinois sans étiquette
apparenté ump débute sa carrière au sein
de l'opposition
et il assure que ses deux mandats sont
compatibles c'est pas du tout compliqué
quand vous êtes proche de paris comment
voyez j'ai un chance d'être un 20
minutes entre les deux bureaux et c'est
non c'est non pas compliqué mais c'est
vraiment utile fait les interventions
que je peux faire elles sont nourries de
l'expérience de terrain
cette double étiquette se heurtera
probablement au projet de loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats voulue par le
président hollande
en attendant françois de mazières
partage son temps entre l'assemblée et
sa commune de versailles est l'un des
dossiers prioritaires de ses députés le
logement social la ministre du logement
cécile duflot soutien à deux projets de
loi la cession des terrains publics aux
communes et l'augmentation du quota de
logements sociaux irréalisable pour le
député françois de mazières il prend
l'exemple de la commune de versailles
dont il est également le maire écoutez
c'est n'est pas raisonnable
on fait oublier ça vraiment été un effet
d'affichage
monter à 25% le quota des logements
sociaux obligatoires
et puis à sortir de multiplication par 5
des sanctions il faut savoir son ville
comme la mienne par exemple ça veut dire
qu'on aurait 2005 deux pénalités 2005
soit une ville comme moi c'est
considérable considérant c'est à dire qu
on limiterait l'investissement ou qu on
augmenterait de 4 points la fiscalité et
ça je crois qu'on n'a pas du tout pris
la dimension de l'impact sur les
communes